oh ah so many seasons just finally this
happened the opening credits will never
be the same oh crap I don't even think
about that huh
okay guys this we don't normally do this
this is not our breakdown this is not
Westeros weekly normally we've watched
the episode like four or five times by
the time you guys see our faces talking
about it we just watched it we just
finished it hi hi I'm Phillip Elena I'm
Erik Bosse we're gonna go through what
we find to be the biggest game changers
of this like game changer after game
changer after game change of a season
finale there's so many huge things just
freakin happened how about we just start
with the obvious
most game-changing thing though whoa
just came down the wall it's no more
well it's kind of it's it's part of the
section of it is gone that section is no
more it's what every single season your
friend is like I bet this season the
walls coming down and it's like know
that for six seasons that guy has just
been building it and this thing is like
it's not gonna happen
and it freakin happens obviously this is
the biggest game-changer a couple
different reasons why first off the
geography of Westeros the wall is like I
said the map it's a defining
characteristic of this continent right
this huge land mass it's 8,000 years old
not just a divider of like you know the
humans and the White Walkers it's also
created entire different cultures the
wildlings don't even speak the same
dialects because they're on the other
side as well and they've waged war
centuries I mean this thing is such a
huge part of the history of these lands
and we were talking earlier how the last
time there was something this
game-changing of the geography of the
children the forest right during the war
with the first men between the children
of the forest they remember destroyed
the arm the land bridge that led Essos
to Westeros in order to stop the
invasion of further men migrating to the
content of Westeros and now this is kind
of a reversal of that right instead of
drawing mode of transportation between
different parts of the continent they're
creating now their ribs between the
north part and the north can you imagine
if we were like had a bridge to North
Korea like it things would not go as
well like if there was easy access it
also reminds me of the children of the
forest trying to sink the neck
oh they Yap they try to do it with an
NDA and they like we're all out of a lot
of love and magic and they couldn't do
it fully so became swamplands but even
it alone becoming swamplands became a
very hard path to traverse and invading
armies having to take these very
specific roads and routes this is the
biggest thing that has ever happened in
this series I thought right this is huge
it's a huge game-changer and let's not
forget the children of the forest
according to legend in the Song of Ice
and Fire series used magic to help
construct this wall so does that mean
that this magical protection if it
exists in the show does that mean that
protection is broken well I know a lot
of people have remembered since the
moment that bran crossed the wall you
know with his the the night Kings mark
that was what was I ruined the magic the
magic okay after that but the three-eyed
Ravens cave was susceptible now to my
king attack because he had his mark and
it enters like well he did that to the
wall too and it's like yeah everyone
seemed to walk through just fine I bet
there was like the first person was like
yeah yeah but also I mean it's not just
the children the force and their magic
it's famously bran the Builder mm-hmm
who built the wall and I know that right
now there's a real hot theory out there
Oh what if bran was bran the Builder
being used as time travelling sort of
abilities to project himself in the past
right he is also brain the Builder the
founder pastor built the wall but also
what if he's the night king train the
night King and if he's the night King
then Brett and bran the Builder brand
built and tore down this wall mr.
Gorbachev tear down the wall so if you
want to know more about this idea of
like wait what how would brand be the
night king we just wrote a shot a video
about it
Bunz I thought that's out any day this
this week yeah keeping out more cool
biggest changing your changing and it
could be even more a game-changer we
don't really know the fates of tormund
and beric Dondarrion are they okay we
have to watch it again frame by frame to
see where they ended up I think I I'm
worried that we're not gonna know the
answer to that until it mic season
because the way they're shot I was
purposely paying attention for it and I
was like uh-uh wait days are going down
really fast so they can get to the
bottom in the holding room right it
could be a literal cliffhanger they
could be literally
yeah just lie and then Derek holding
from his beard for depth perception
because of the eyepatch oh yeah he's
swinging for that next biggest
game-changing moment Littlefinger kicked
the bucket I was hoping you'd give us
some beer a little finger impression
it's the only one I like I so this is
huge because this is a you know a season
one character that was masterfully
portrayed and we should remember that
Littlefinger is actually like a very
interesting character we just have since
gotten kind of annoyed with him but but
this is a game changer now moving
forward because little finger represents
political manipulation in Westeros and
honestly politics and Westeros and the
squabbles of men and that just ran out
you know that just no longer has a place
yeah I game of Thrones without
Petyr Baelish in it is a different world
entirely it's less of a chessboard and
now it's just more of those straight-up
battlefield right it's you gotta think
people like you know a knight king that
is gonna destroy a wall but also people
I always refer to Iran as an agent of
chaos like like his rule is not coming
to play and conveniently right as the
show is running out of like things that
I could do to surprise this it's like
well what if we get rid of just the idea
of like plans being laid out it's just
gonna be chaos for the entirety of next
season
there is the interesting thing that
Cersei is still trying to play a
political game right usurped his role as
the master manipulator of this series
but we saw how it didn't really work out
for little things right again
you know is a
foretell anything for Cersei I think sir
she's gonna win I think she's gonna win
the whole thing if you know we got
totally fair yeah it's also interesting
that that moment it I love that that
idea that it's the two sisters just like
he came between the two sisters of the
previous generation of their mother and
their aunt Lysa that exact thing came
back and it was the the two sisters but
this time their bond was stronger and
you know they were Starks so they do
have a slightly stronger bond they were
the ones that take him down but it also
weighs on Sansa a lot which of course
this guy was is almost like a creepy
fatherly uncle to her or whatever but
killing someone you know are you sure
BEC hey it was it was you bastard
sentence and sense of look I know I'm
trying to pretend that it wasn't me that
don't like this blood on my hands right
yeah so now them having blood on their
hands well our yeah there's buckets of
blood like this yeah but does that make
Sansa
even more like Cersei which is what I've
been doing all season her arc well in
speaking of Cersei it's interesting that
Sansa created this idea of like a false
trial and yeah right we're a little
finger there which is pretty much how
sort of sounds Cersei right up no public
defender like this is a real trial a
jury stenographer nowhere to be yeah
yeah there was yeah right women is
carving into a stupid chess plate
yeah but in both cases the trial that
people are led there to believe that
would happen ended up not happening at
all and instead there was a violent
death of a major character it did kind
of feel like for a second Santa was
gonna be like I sentence you to the pit
Oh Daria what do you do didn't even like
was just in the middle of a moment hmm
the executioner was in the cornered it's
all sad even though I've all season been
like if they're gonna go down this path
it's got to lead to the Littlefinger's
death even though I saw it coming in
that way and I was annoyed by it I still
kind of liked it I still was like you
know what if you gave the the stark
sisters something to do together I
actually do appreciate that it's
something that is almost tied to their
storylines like Aria becoming like an
assassin right and and and brute force
killer and then Sansa dealing with all
the things she dealt with but these were
crimes of men mm-hmm that they've dealt
with and
even the people that are you had killed
they're the people that have done things
against mankind they're not really they
weren't ready to play the white Walker
game like imagine if like that had been
thing where stances like I'm going to
try to take on the night king myself
it's like you don't know maybe next
season first you you have to like tie up
this thing and a little finger again
politics needed to be tied up so I am
happy that it happened even though it
was kind of like mmm please I don't like
one characters that are on the same side
fight and it kind of felt like we were
back in season one or two or three words
major characters were used to seeing or
finally actually die in the show it has
the courage to kill off major kids
that's why I viously they've got to
bring back next season the major
character of little Robin Arryn because
he's now in charge of the bail again and
he's gonna be there like night King I
choose you I don't know be the bars to
go immediately runs into a hole and
floor people attic for him
alright next biggest game-changing
moment and you guess it John's real name
right yeah yeah and it's not just John
sand which brand thought it would
because he was born in Dorne and there's
a little bit of an ass about it it's
like Sam I don't know if you know your
names of bastards like I do but it
meanwhile like Sam's about to be smarter
than if I had been reading acceptance
diary yeah I've been ignoring my
girlfriend and I know that Aegon
Targaryen or Aegon I think on even we've
been saying egg on for as long as we've
known this series but I'm gonna call out
that in the little flashback
it sounded like egg on yeah hey butch
like on a gun yeah yeah and Duncan egg
right that would be probably the
namesake right hey gun well no
not-not-not that we actually have no way
of knowing which which should be named
it yeah because this a little confusing
right because at least according to the
books Rhaegar and Ellie are Elia Martell
had previous children one of them was
named egg on that was the child who was
killed during a sack in King's Landing
to clarify that the second of King's
Landing in the territory these are
back-to-back events it's that's like
like oh your kid just died I'm so sorry
can I have that name
right such a good name I just can't pass
up that because the timeline isn't
totally clear we don't know if Rhaegar
and Lyanna decided on this name together
because they would have gotten married
perhaps before the baby was killed or if
that was a name that Liana decided after
the baby was killed and that's just the
name she whispered to her brother Ned
potentially like she'd always had a
fondness toward that name and she but
she would definitely know if she's you
know this man is stepping out on his
lady with her she would know all that
ladies do we know all that drum yeah
maybe she's well now the name Akon is
free it's pretty awkward it's not it
would be less awkward if it was like a
grown up
yes I call he died but in his name after
him it's like we're gonna immediately
it's a baby and we're gonna name the
next baby the same name well there's a
tenday I guess it's like they have like
monogrammed pillows or they don't have
this like well it's all assuming of
course that the show is sticking exactly
to the history of the books it could
happen to where they change right into
the kids the the name has egg on I'm not
certain if the name egg on wasn't even a
baby in the show right yeah they've said
in this show cuz they talked about and
her baby mm-hmm you know they wait yeah
older children yeah all the Princess
Bride speech that he gives this is
actually a good connection is so John
has a totally different name that's a
game-changer but obviously the other
game changes this stems Adam is us seen
the Targaryen stark wedding this houses
United that's not just like oh yeah we
knew that they were married the reason
why at least why I feel like this is a
game-changing moment is how many times
in the history of this show of Game of
Thrones do does the show like make news
over the books what I mean by that is
this and this has never happened in the
books it's been this theory that people
have had since then early 90s when the
books came out it was you know partially
the question that Benioff and Weiss
cover asked whether who jon snow's real
mother was in order for them to even get
the rights to be able to produce this
show so this thing is like the biggest
mystery of the history of this thing and
we just saw it officially yes they were
together yes it was out of love yes the
entire war of the usurper was over like
of
girl like not being totally honest with
her but like inna I'm not that into I'm
actually into the print it was a
consensual legitimate marriage yeah and
so that is something that like I have
like books on Game of Thrones it's like
so funny to me I was like this book is
now inaccurate right it talks about
these reasons and who everyone was and
how Jon's of astronautics things it's
like no it's officially confirmed I know
what felt like it was confirmed earlier
in season but Gilly getting like kind of
head or whatever and saying the names
wrong she didn't even say Liana's name
right she said rag er bride who's
raggert right Oh Gregor so now this
level of confirmation a bunch of people
that like print the history of Game of
Thrones related book sort of early all
right now we got to change this whole
thing I still don't know how they're
gonna revealed in the books cuz it's not
revealed in the books yet which might
crazy but that's just that's as
game-changing as the wall the history
lessons like now you have new history
lessons right it's just like when the
Berlin Wall fell they had to rewrite the
history textbook you can tell how old
your book is my neighbor first to the
USSR all the time Russia's a lot bigger
history book but now like the history
books are being rewritten and I assume
John and Daenerys wish they had gotten
this history textbook because mmm is
that our I guess that's our next game
changer yeah right John and Danny uh
well it's classically we're just
blinking blinking mandy they really
edited that to be as awkward as it could
be huh right oh you did we can't talk
about it in too much detail visit the
baby yeah this is obviously a game
changer because these two are hooking up
but also I mean this is starting to go
down the line a prophesied all right
stuff
yes as we know from book two there was
that whole vision that Daenerys
experienced in the house of the undying
Daenerys saw this person who many
believe is her deceased brother Rhaegar
text and brother it's her brother yeah
and he's holding a baby and he brings up
that whole point about the Song of Ice
and Fire
but like the product is the Song of Ice
and Fire he also has been like super
weird about it like
he needs a whole other baby because
they've only had two he's like no there
must be three heads to the dragon so
that kind of stuff though is kind of
over Frank to hear that I he's ice and
she's fired and whatever is being
produced here is literally the Song of
Ice and Fire
so in whatever is being produced you're
kind of like talking around it I mean
this like but when Caine is probably
leading the pregnancy like it's just
kind of immediately and I love that John
almost out of the exact way I said a lot
of time words like so some witch told
you you were barren and that's why
you're screaming at everybody I'm barren
[Music]
so I think that they're immediately
jumping to that like no she's gonna get
pregnant again
potentially that could be azor Ahai
right that could be the prince that was
promised and in fact as we know from
part of that prophecy is that it would
goes through that Targaryen lineage that
both John and a nurse are a part of from
whom azor Ahai the prince was promised
would come from and they always said it
was gonna be tween ha aunt and her cute
nephew yeah that's one of the prophecy
bleeds oh uh
but speaking of incestuous hookups how
about news shows breakups our next big
game-changer
Jamie and Cersei the Lannisters power
couple of Westeros dungeon mmm I feel
like Perez Hilton of Westeros which is
what Littlefinger would have been or if
he we're not just saying that this is a
game-changing moment because a big
breakup I Cersei is just now being set
up we didn't know this as almost like
the biggest villain of the show which
first off I think is amazing for how
they introduced the character is she's
just like a tart almost like like just
this unimportant character and we see
her getting railed and like Jamie's in
the position of power over her it's like
who is she she's so unimportant now
she's being set up to be the biggest
villain like kind of over the night king
and the reason I say that is because
Tyrion had so clearly just made a
reference to the idea of her having any
heart left well her heart is Jaime Jaime
was the only heart she had left so her
not having any heart left that is why
she would be turning her
on humanity like those go hand in hand
to how big of a villain can you be
you're just saying like oh I'm not
siding with humans on this yeah
Jamie was the last redeeming quality to
her and now if you're looking at Jamie
he is now clearly someone who's siding
with the heroes of the show like this he
was on this Redemption arc over the
entire series especially since season 3
when he revealed his side of the
kingslayer's story and for a second we
were kind of worried that he was taking
a couple steps backward trying to keep
this relationship alive with Cersei but
now it's clear that he's no longer
interested in that and he just wants to
be part of this war against the White
Walkers which it's gonna be a decision
that everyone on the off of the show
like the audience and the characters
that are gonna receive him have to make
of like okay have you earned it do we
feel like you've earned it can we root
for you are you on our side and I mean I
I'm fin on the side Jamie for a little
while but I definitely get why some
people are like I will never be able to
reflect him next biggest game-changing
moment the dragon pit scene the whole
frickin thing all the major big players
in the show for the most part might
maybe - Sansa and Arya they're all in
the same place together they all have
reasons to hate each other they're all
staring each other yeah totally in the
eyes
my favorite thing isn't just how every
season has pointed in this direction for
years and years and years of like when
is that gonna happen it's the fact that
now because it's been so long there is
so much drama packed into these moments
so Dany is meeting the Queen who was the
wife of the guy who sent the assassins
after her yeah John is now down here and
he's seen the people that killed med
Stark the man he believes as his father
also orchestrated the red wedding right
killing his half-brother and the mother
that it was always kind of horrible to
him but still a stark Jaime killed
Danny's dad oh sure yeah the ink Slayer
right and of course big one Cersei and
Tyrion to Cersei she's hated Tyrion
she's this is a guy who if it didn't
kill Joffrey at least killed Tywin and
left her the entire Lannister family
exposed and as we see in the next scene
she blames him for
the deaths of Tommen and Marcella which
is so unfair right so there's a lot of
things gonna go into that but at the
moment those two talk that was
personally my biggest one where I was
like ah they said words to each other
and it was like it is always that way I
don't know if you've ever had like a big
dramatic reunion like that with someone
where you kind of like end up saying
something to them it's kind of like what
time is it 8:30 like it's like the
stupidest thing you don't immediately go
like you right and like that's what it
was like it's like she'll be here soon
yeah like that was there like a huge
first thing but I was like oh my god
they just spoke to each other since the
frickin crossbow yeah and think about
how this is all a game changer like up
until this point on Game of Thrones this
has been like several different series
each one has kind of had a different
color palette even to it and now this
feels like a crossover believe this is
Simpsons meeting The Jeffersons meeting
The Flintstones right Game of Thrones
yeah oh yeah next biggest game-changer
only because it told us it confirmed for
us that the show's gonna do it clicking
balls they clearly were like oh you want
to see it right we got to save something
for next season so they made a new
promise of like you know what's coming
for you that that means to me at least
that they're like turning to the
audience over like you know what's
coming I click any bowl is gonna happen
I'm right I put money on it and I'm
putting it right there at Season eight
yeah what other reason would they have
these two brothers meeting faced this
totally felt like a setup for a big
wrestling event little something's
coming for your brother season one
little thing yeah yeah they did have a
different accent yeah so we're gonna
hold off on getting really into that one
because you know we'll see it eventually
that's a maybe like the WWE version of
like a big game changer there's actually
another very subtle game changer that
kind of like two subsets and that's the
rebirth of Theon Greyjoy he is obviously
from a family that had a lot of like
lore about the concept of being reborn
and being drowned and coming back and it
also obviously is very similar to
Christianity the kind of the idea of
being baptized right and and now you
fully are who you are but
that coinciding with the moment that
John just told him he's a stark mm-hmm
and I know he said he's a stark and he's
a Greyjoy
but really I mean the being a Greyjoy is
no brainer part the fact that he said he
was a stark
I almost got like choked about it I was
like really big on the story uh
and so just having this Theon now that
remember it was only a few episodes ago
we're like oh he's Rica again and it's
like not like now moving forward he got
he's real ugly now they beat the crap
out of him but he's beyond Greyjoy -
stark - Rodriguez I'm so excited right
it's like being reminded of the stark
influence on his life bring him strength
it was kind of like his power up and
daddy getting kicked in the not balls
right that gives him strength I mean
there is probably a wound it's probably
what hurts it anyone to get kicked
anywhere it's it no it doesn't make you
feel good when you get kind of like hey
like it was like a obi-wan like kicked
me in the balls and I come back stronger
harder and stronger
well not harder but this did give beyond
a new sense of purpose right this is a
game trade we've always seen him up
until this point since he lost a big
part of him okay kind of wallowing in
despair not really sure which direction
he was going in when he was reunited
with the sister that gave him a sense of
direction but now he knows his endgame
his final goal is to repay his sister
for the for the service she did for him
which that might kill him that might be
the journeys on but it also answers the
question of why do we still have this
character on this show and it's cuz he
needed to go all the way through not
just to some Redemption that's like a
forgiveness redemption of the thing with
Sansa where he like saved her but
literally for himself like just saving
someone isn't like okay now I undid
everything and John very much calls that
out he has to now finally solve his
initial problem which if you go back to
the opening episode the pilot of this
show you can see that Theon Greyjoy is
having this struggle of well yeah but
like grey juries are really cool too but
also like the Starks don't like me no
one here likes me like he's been trying
to settle that for seven seasons now
and that is why like the character
suddenly got interesting again today
probably saw that was like okay now
anything that goes is on the outside of
his arc it usually means he might die
but at the same time at least it's like
oh it justified so many things so many
things that we've seen like this is what
it was all building towards this moment
where the king of the freakin north be
it your pseudo brother cousin kind of
guy just said he forgives you and your
stark which at that moment being a stark
Lacanian or at least he thinks this is
one of the most noble things that you
could receive it's almost like being
knighted every being a a terrible person
right but guys we have so much work to
do obviously on this we still I'm still
I'm blowing your questions right now for
his first weekly there's a lot of big
ones like for instance and like not only
who's actually dead but what was going
on with Tyrion in that moment on the
boat there's a lot of emotion going on
there like I don't know what it what
they're trying to say about what Tyrion
was thinking about somebody in that room
I'm gonna say who sir Davos you know
I've gotten stuck in here not much of a
fight I'm sick Polonius like van the
curtain much of a bite what but also we
got the breakdown coming out later this
week so keep an eye out for it they did
so many cool specific things with this
episode there's a lot of details I'm
dying to dig into specifically the music
score this episode was amazing Jawad II
did so many cool things creating new
songs out of familiar ones that you
might have heard before but waking them
little interesting ways so keep an eye
out for that breakdown I also like well
I'll tell you how cameras like you put
in the breakdown but Songdo specifically
used in the exact opposite way that it
was used before
yeah so check out all the Game of
Thrones content were so gonna have this
week so the Westeros weekly tomorrow is
the breakdown weighted the week and then
also that video about brain being the
night King yeah it's possible otherwise
thanks so much for watching this guys it
was a fun world thing that we we've
never done before but hopefully you
liked it and subscribe to this channel
if you don't already because we do
really crazy in-depth Game of Thrones
coverage like go watch any of our other
game in terms of
you know we go real deep but that's it
right if you have any questions you can
tweet them at me at EA boss at fimo and
make sure to use the hashtag Westeros
weekly so that we'll see it more easily
and feature it in some of the videos
that we do cool thanks so much see you
next time right bye